[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i knew one guy was going to be happy
today he's our next guest he's carson
palmer former nfl quarterback and of
course a heisman trophy winner at usc
his weekly appearance brought to you by
our good partner level select cbd
looking for next
level relief visit levelselectcbd.com
all right so what'd you think of the
hire with lincoln riley
yeah it's a good day to be a trojan dan
i think that one kind of came out of
left field nobody was expecting it
nobody was really talking about it his
name wasn't thrown around the rumorville
and now he's he's headed to la to be the
next coach at usc and i think it's a
fantastic win for the trojans okay i
know that we you know we got you in a
little bit of trouble when you brought
up mike tomlin's name on the wish list
but was lincoln riley's name on that
wish list like with
and if so how far back
oh he was he would have been at the top
of the list i just don't think anybody
really
knew his current contract situation he
only has or had one year left on his
deal in oklahoma
you know it seemed like a great fit you
know for for him to stay at oklahoma for
the long haul uh he'd had a ton of
success and and come in i think in four
or five years been to the been to the
playoffs three of the four years three
to five years so um
you know it just it just wasn't on his
name was not on paper people's radar and
uh i think for a majority of ufc fans
across the country if they would have
known lincoln was in the running
he would have been at the top of
everybody's list okay is there somebody
that you thought was going to get it
well i think the obvious tie was the
luke fickle tie with the university of
cincinnati and and mike bone the current
usc athletic director having hired coach
fickle to cincinnati when when mike was
at cincinnati it just was a natural fit
but this one i mean at this timing you
just didn't feel this timing
you didn't think there was going to be
announcement coming over thanksgiving
weekend but
like i said i mean just a huge win for
all trojans but if you're a high school
quarterback and let's say you're four or
five star recruit
um it feels like those quarterbacks have
been leaving southern california is is
lincoln riley enough for these you know
high school seniors to say i'm going to
stay here in in southern california
oh absolutely i mean he's just look at
the last two quarterbacks he had and and
kyler murray and baker mayfield both of
them went number one in the draft both
of them won heisman trophies you know
they didn't have a ton of time to work
under lincoln and
under his tutelage to really develop but
he developed them extremely quickly
which if you look at high school
recruits right now what's important
is quick success nobody wants to go to
go to university and wait two or three
years and be the starter and you know
wait for his turn guys want to go into
college and play now and they want to
have success early so if you're a young
a young high school kid with those kind
of aspirations and you just look at the
track record of what lincoln riley's
done in a short amount of time with
kyler murray in a short amount of time
with with baker mayfield i mean that
that's proven success very very quick
very fast so i think that's um you know
a great recruiting tool that lincoln can
go into these high school kids living
rooms and sit in front of their mom and
dad and say hey look the proof's in the
pudding i only had a year with kyler i
had a very short amount of time with
baker and i've i've found a way to get
the best and to put the best uh talent
out on the field around these players
and i think that's been a big factor in
their success also
i think it's a great hire for usc i
think it's a smart move logistically for
for lincoln riley because you can sort
of
have that big 12 feel but now you're in
the pac-12
because oklahoma's going to the sec
you can still stand alone a little bit
like you did with oklahoma in the big 12
and you can do that in the pac-12
what do you think
oh absolutely it's much more difficult
to get to the bull championship uh to
get to the playoffs in the sec you got
to worry about georgia you got to worry
about florida you got alabama and lsu
and so on
in the pac-12 you've really got oregon
if you're usc and i know they just got
beat a couple weeks ago by ucla but for
the most part
you know you've got a much easier route
to get to the playoffs going at gunman
from the pac-12 i mean oregon's
consistently pretty pretty good i mean
you know over the years last 10-15 years
oregon's really the only challenger that
sc's had with an outlier every once in a
while with stanford that's had a couple
good years
you know washington state you know has a
couple good years every once in a while
but for the most part it's a usc oregon
conference you go look at the the sec
everybody's a contender outside of a
couple of schools
yeah i get it and uh you know he did a
lot of recruiting in southern california
too and then you're going to get these
kids who are going to decommit from
oklahoma and probably follow him to usc
you've already got a couple i mean
you're already starting to hear
rumblings there's a couple great players
that at modern day which is one of the
powerhouses in southern california and
really one of the powerhouse high
schools in the country and they've got
two five-star recruits the running back
and the quarterback both were committed
to oklahoma i wouldn't be surprised to
see those guys change their minds and
stay home i mean that it's it's tough to
leave southern california when you're a
high school football player and it's
really tough to leave southern
california and go to norman oklahoma
and then you factor in you know the
family and friends that are close that
can now come and see you and get in a
car and drive and watch you play at sc
compared to getting on a flight or three
flights getting to norman um you know he
he's going to start getting that kind of
pete carroll respect from the recruiting
class this is where everybody out of
california
sc is in their top five when pete
carroll was there and i think you're
going to see that same thing with with
lincoln riley you have not seen that and
it's from the clay hilton area there's
tons of kids that don't even take a trip
to sc and they go
to the sec they go to the big 12 they've
had headed outside of california they've
gone to oregon now i think you're going
to see that pete carroll following of of
these high school kids in california
staying in state and giving sc a really
hard look what was the wildest thing
that happened on a recruiting trip for
you
i had a great recruiting trip to the
university of colorado when when rick
knew heisel was there um
and
colorado wasn't a big powerhouse at the
time i just i just had a great
relationship with coach new heisel and
really really liked him and wanted to be
a part of what he had going at colorado
at the time
and our recruiting trip we we went
paintballing we went river rafting
we we just did some outside the box
things that you wouldn't expect to do on
a recruiting trip and that was part of
you know that was what one of the things
that made rick new heisel such a great
recruiter he was a phenomenal recruiter
as he found ways to exploit the places
that he was university of washington
ucla colorado he used the uh he used all
the things he had in his own backyard to
attract kids you just wanted a free trip
to colorado didn't you you weren't going
there no doubt
no i mean i
i i hadn't been to boulder i'd heard
good things and and at the time new
heisel had them they were an up and
coming program
um
you know being a southern california kid
you wanted to get outside of socal and
go see i went to notre dame i went um to
colorado and sc and had a blast on all
my recruiting trips okay no names but
what were you offered
anything interesting anywhere
no i mean i that when i was coming up
and then when i was in the league i was
always hearing stories about a number of
sec schools um there's you know when
when you go to usc
you got to be so careful if if there are
if there are extracurricular activities
going on and
you know kids are getting paid pre the
the name image and likeness world
there there's a nla there's you you usc
grads ucla grads oregon and washington
you go on down the list you go to
tuscaloosa alabama there's not a whole
bunch of auburn fans you go to baton
rouge there's not a bunch of georgia
bulldogs in that area and they protect
their own so all the stories i heard
were coming out of the sec where they
were really small college towns and they
could really control who was seeing some
so and so ride around in a new mercedes
or a new cadillac escalade
we're talking to carson palmer who got
offered nothing to go to usc
right a great education of course great
education yes i know i paid for two of
those educations all right um
when you're playing and you want to play
but you know that you're not helping
your team play
who's it on to take baker out or
you know matthew stafford looked like he
was banged up yesterday at some point
when does who makes that decision that
it's better for us if you're not out
there trying to gut this out
it's a team decision and when you're
talking about the quarterback of a
franchise it's a decision between baker
the team doctor
the head team trainer the owner the gm
and the head coach you can't just put it
on the player because the player is
always going to say i'm good i'm fine
it's a it's it's a collective discussion
where everybody puts you know puts their
weight in makes their that makes their
decision comes up with why the reasons
why why not but you can't put it on one
individual and right now it looks like
baker's hurt and and the good thing that
the cleveland browns have in their back
pocket is case kingdom case keenum is a
flat player i mean it hasn't worked out
great when he's a starter year after
year after year but when he can spell a
banged up you know shoulder that baker
may have or rib or whatever the issues
he has you can still win a lot of games
with with him especially with the talent
they have so you know the the best thing
that baker has in the cleveland browns
have right now is case keenum and it
looks like
you know it looks like baker's banged up
and if if that group of
of mines get together and decide that
the best thing for the team is case
keenum that they need to make that
decision i didn't understand this logic
and you could certainly help uh
understand this
you got aaron rodgers playing on a toe
that might need surgery
if you're the rams why aren't you going
out of your way let's just put pressure
on him i know he can carve you up he's
looking for the blitz and all of those
things but i have to make him
uncomfortable
and it just didn't feel like the rams
made rogers as uncomfortable as they
should have
yeah you would like to see them come out
in the first three or four drives and
just put a ton of pressure on and make
him move make him get in some
uncomfortable situations and and get off
balance and throw off platform where he
has to put a little more weight on that
pinky toe and get him uncomfortable like
you said but you know they just kind of
sat out and said we're going to try to
cover them we're going to keep the ball
in front of us you i i personally would
have liked them to see put a ton of
pressure on them early and if he gets
you in the first two or three drives you
can then back off and sit and play zone
and keep the ball in front of you and
not let them throw it over your head but
it just was too easy i mean when you see
these quarterbacks that are banged up
and then you know sunday night was a
great example
baltimore knew that that
he was hurting they could tell baker was
hurting they've read all the press
clippings they've seen it and they came
after him i mean they they were bringing
not cover zero full pressures but they
consistently brought pressure and got
him out outside the pocket made him move
made him get off platform and throw some
balls that you know
you know typically a healthy baker would
make but an injured baker is not going
to make and you would like to have seen
that um with with the rams yesterday but
for whatever reason they came back and
they wanted to keep the ball in front of
them and they got almost 40 points on
them unfortunately
yeah i just i wonder about that because
he might be playing himself out of
getting that long-term contract by
wanting to play to help this team
yeah i mean that that tough guy
mentality is something that that you
want your quarterback to have every
organization wants their franchise
player to say i can play no matter what
but again this group of doctors and
professionals and gm's and head coach
they need to get together
and and make that decision as a team and
what's best for the team but
from from a contractual standpoint going
forward i mean you can't sit here and
say that baker's earned a long-term
contract that's going to pay him 40
million bucks a year it's just flat out
the play on the field has not shown that
he's worth 30 40 50 million bucks a year
which which is where these contracts are
heading currently so
they're in a tough spot i mean it's it's
tough not to resign and give a long-term
extension to a guy that's a number one
pick a guy that's kind of kept you
somewhat in the playoff hunt every year
he's been there
um but not getting in the playoffs and
with the talent they have they've got
some huge decisions to make this
offseason as a former great quarterback
when i see aaron rodgers and i'm talking
about you being the former great
quarterback
aaron rodgers just it still feels like
there's a backyard mentality to how he
plays that position
that you know the guy in the backyard
the quarterback's always the best
athlete and and it still feels that way
how does he
how's he able to do it where he it feels
like it's it's when he's great it's as
effortless as anybody who plays in the
game
it's as unorthodox as anybody i've ever
seen play the position i mean you you
know it's funny as as the last 20 years
have progressed the position of playing
quarterback and it started back in the
day with the san francisco 49ers and the
steve youngs and the joe montana's the
progression
one hitch two hitch first second read
third read four three and you go through
progression you read the curl in the
flat to the hook to the checkdown
he doesn't play the game that way and
very very few guys i mean another guy
that really doesn't play that game that
way is mahomes you rarely see them take
a five step drop
one hitch two hits three hitch throw i
mean sometimes aaron's in a back pedal
sometimes he's in a
traditional drop back sometimes he's
doing some sort of pump fake at the line
of scrimmage to pump the now and they
you know pump a draw he's he's just
absolutely like you're saying that he's
playing in the backyard and looking for
somebody
in the right mismatch situation looking
for somebody just to give him a sliver
of room to fit a ball into but as far as
playing the game the way that we're all
taught even these young kids coming up
right now they're taught it's a purely
progression game aaron does not go
through progressions he looks for a
mismatch finds a way to manipulate the
pocket extend the play and try to go for
the big chunk play and not throw that
check down when the defense is dictating
that this ball needs to be thrown to the
checkdown he's just not willing to take
that five yard throw he wants that 25
yard back shoulder throw that we see him
do week in and week out
as you said a couple of weeks ago
you know teaching young kids don't
emulate aaron rodgers
because you can't and and probably the
same with mahomes but but if you sat
down with him could he teach you
something about what he does
that you wouldn't be aware of right now
oh absolutely i mean there's so much
going on
um that we as as nfl fans can't see from
from the nbc cut or the fox cut if we
had the coaches cut which is that that
camera that's at the very top of the
stadium that's showing all 22 players in
the field at the same time you can pick
up some things that way but
who knows i mean that's why he's so
difficult to coach and you've seen kind
of coaches there always seem to be
somewhat on the hot seat and you know
you know from mccarthy and and then out
the issues with the floor we were
hearing about uh early on this year and
last season he's got to be difficult to
coach because
you know you can call a play and number
one is not open but number two is wide
open and he over he just moves right
past number two and every once in a
while he'll take a sack waiting for
number three or number four hoping
number four comes open in his read
and that's gotta drive coaches
absolutely nuts but absolutely hands
down he is worth the headache
concerns about the rams
i'm not i mean i i know they've they've
had a couple tough weeks in a row um
but at the end of the day odell beckham
is still trying to figure it out matt
stafford is still trying to figure him
out we're gonna see there's enough
season left before the playoffs start
that we're gonna start to see those two
guys mesh a little bit more you saw
odell catch the slugo the slant go route
for the touchdown we're going to start
seeing more of that he's getting more
more comfortable with the formations and
that's one thing you got to realize
about a sean mcvay offense is there is
so much going on before the ball is
snapped there are so many shifts motions
movements
checks that are happening that you just
can't come in and pick those up no
matter how smart you are in two or three
weeks those are going to take a month a
month and a half so i mean this team is
just loaded with talent they have some
of the best defensive players in all of
football they have some of the best
offensive players in all of football and
when you have that combined with that
coach
it's a good recipe i look to see them
getting in the playoffs and really
picking up some steam you gave us piss
missile last week you promised uh
another one this week so uh what are you
offering up with football jargon
dan i'm not an off-the-cuff kind of guy
it's it's uh it's gotta come naturally
you told me
you said i said give me more and you go
wait till next week
you didn't prepare you did not prepare
film stuff i woke up at two i woke up at
two this morning preparing for the dp
show
so i've been preparing all morning but
it's it's gotta naturally and
organically come off the top you can't
just ask for a list of them okay maybe
next week that's the cliffhanger
[Laughter]
all right well congratulations on your
trojans you're back
we're back baby thank you bud that's uh
carson palmer joining us courtesy of
level select cbd
the uh next level relief level select
cpd